I use simplified numbers when we first
thought about how the Chinese government
can intervene in foreign currency
markets to keep their currency devalued
what I want to do in this video is to
actually look at some of the real
numbers so this is from the US Bureau of
Economic Analysis B ei gov this is the
URL where I actually got this data and
this right over here is the US balance
of payments relative to China and this
part right over here is the current
account which is really tells us the
imports versus exports and this over
here is the capital account sometimes
called the financial account depending
on depending on how you are accounting
for it and this tells us about the
inflow or the outflow of ownership of
assets so this is goods this is assets
you could think of it's money or
securities or other things like that now
you can look from 2006 2006 we did
export some things to China 72 billion
worth in 2006 this is in millions of
dollars so 72 thousand is 72 billion
increased to 85 billion 95 billion
stated around 95 billion in 2009 but but
the United States imported a ton more
330 billion 330 billion in 2006 380
billion in 2007 almost 400 billion in
2009 so we're running almost a 300
billion almost a 300 billion trade
deficit in 2008 relative to China and
then in 2009 it goes down a little bit
this looks like about a 260 billion
trade deficit and that's really just
because we imported we imported or the
United States imported
fewer goods and to large degree that was
probably because of the u.s. the u.s.
recession we're consumption in general
when consumption in general slowed down
so we would have bought fewer goods and
services from pretty much anyone
including ourselves or China now you can
see that being offset in the financial
account this to some degree tells the
story it's doesn't give us the full
story of the Chinese and this isn't just
the Chinese government this is all
Chinese ownership that they're that they
are increasing their ownership of US
assets and those assets they could be US
Treasury notes and Bill
these could be US stocks this could be
US real estate but you can see each year
and this is the increase Americans are
buying assets in China five billion
dollars in 2006 two billion in 2007 12
billion in 2008 18 billion in 2009 to
some degree this is limited by a
restrictions imposed by the Chinese
government but you can see the Chinese
are buying way more assets in the US and
this really this really kind of is part
of that picture of the Chinese
especially the Chinese central
government is buying US assets to do
that they have to buy dollars with wen
which keeps the dollar strong and allows
their currency to stay weak which to
some degree allows or to a large degree
allows this balance of the trade deficit
to stay where it is now I'll leave you
with one conundrum to a large degree
this is these numbers right here they
are offsetting the trade deficit and
especially in 2008 the Chinese bought
way more US assets than actually even
the trade deficit they more than made up
for it but in 2009 you don't see them
buying enough to make up for the trade
deficit they bought a hundred forty
three billion and actually on a net
basis it'll probably be about 120
something billion which doesn't make up
for the whole 260 billion so how did
they still keep their currency pegged
and the answer and we'll look at that
into more detail is they don't have to
directly buy US assets they could buy
assets or they could buy currency from
another country and that will put that
will put upward pressure on that
currency so let me put it over here
China China could go and buy US currency
or it could go to a another country and
buy their currency country a and then
country a is going to feel pressure its
currency is going to go up in value and
it doesn't want that because it would
hurt its trade so then it might go and
buy US assets to keep it devalued then
that would not show up in that chart but
we'll look at that in the next video
this is Salman Khan of the Khan Academy
for CNBC